LAST FOUR GAMES FOR HIM.
AND AUSTON
AUSTON MATTHEWS, THE TEAM LEADER
WITH SIX POWERPLAY GOALS ON THE
YEAR, AND FOR YOU BACK IN GOAL.
ALL.
>> Gord: 6'5", 230 POUNDS, RUBE
FOR BELLEMARE
TO GET  BACK
TO THE S SMAN MOVES IN
ACROSS THE LINE AND DROPS IT
BACK TO KILLORN.
UP T
RADDYSHTHE LEAGUE.
TORONTO FIRST, THE LIGHTNINNH A.
HERE'S MUZZIN WITH IT. ON THE S
WALL, PRETTY EASY TURNOVER.
THAT PUCK'S GOT TO BE ACORNER.
>> Gord: GOAL AGAINST
PHILADELPHIA ON SUNDAYILL FIND
PALAT, THIS HIT OFF OF
NYLANDER'S STICK COMING BACK T
IT WAS WAVED OFF AS REILLY WENT
BACK AND PLAYED IT BACK ACRO, P
THE TOP OF THE NET.
LEAFS F RUTTA.
SIMMONDS GOT AIT.
TAVARES BACK AT THE POINT,SHORT.
SHELDON KEEFE LOOKS TO GET ONE
LATEEVSKIY GLOVES
HEDMAN TURNED IT OVER AND HE
WENT TO FLIP IT OUT A IN BACK T
GAMES. BY IT.
BACK IS RITCHIE T
VASILEVSKIY MAKES THE SAVE.
PRESSING BACK WITHIN ONE HEE LI
THEIR ZONE, THEY'RE TIRED,  PRON
THE PUCK LOOSE IN FRONT,
MCDO
THE LIGHTNING WILL GET THE PUCK
OUT.